شكرا للزميل نايف مشاهدي الكرام اسعد الله
اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى ساعه
اخباريه مفصله نخصص معظمها لتطورات المشهد
السوداني نبدا بابرز
المبعوث الامامي للسودان يقول ان الطرفي
الصراع والقاع على ارسال مندوبين للتفاوض
لوضع حد للازمه الحاليه
تجدد الاشتباكات في محيط القصر الجمهوري
رغم الهدنه والطائرات الجيش تحلق في سماء
الخرطوم
وعمليات الاجلاء من بورتسودان تستمر هربا
من المواجهات وتسعه واربعون رحله اجلاء
جويه تصل الى جده
وفي هذه الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
عيد العمال في فرنسا يتحولوا لتظاهرات
حاشده تمديدا باصلاح نظام التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم رغم الهدنه المعلنه في السودان
الا ان مراسل العربيه رصد الشبكات
المتقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع تركزت
في محيط القصر الجمهوري حيث تصاعدت اعمده
الدخان في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم الجيش قال
ان الدعم السريع فقد نصف قدراته العسكريه
منذ بدء المواجهات مؤكدا استقرار الموقف
العمليتين
ومع استمرار خرق الهدنات المعلنه لم يجد
الاف السودانيين الا النزوح سبيلا للهرب
من الاقتتال الدائر
هذا وقال المبعوث الاممي الى السودان ان
طرفي الصراع وفقاع على ارسال مندوبين
للتفاوض بين الجانبين واضاف في حديث
لوكاله
ان المحادثات ستعقد على الارجح في
السعوديه
المبعوث الاممي قال ان التفاوض سيركز في
المقام الاول على ترسيخ وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل مستمر وموثوق مع وضع فكره انشاء اليه
لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار تضم مراقبين
سودانيين واجانب
وفي تصريحات اخرى حول الاوضاع الانسانيه
قال بيرس ان العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه
الخاصه بالامم المتحده تم نهبها مشيرا الى
ان الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثيا
العديد من المساعدات الغذائيه التي كانت
موجوده في المخازن تم نهبها كل المخازن
برنامج الغذاء العالمي ومفوضيه الشؤون
اللاجئين في دارفور مركبات الاغاثه تعرضت
للسرقه مكاتبي ايضا في دارفور تعرضت
للسرقه لم يتم احترام وقف اطلاق النار
بشكل كامل كان الالتزام جزئيا وفي مواقع
دون الاخرى
وفي اليوم السابع عشر شهد السودان هدوءا
حذرا رغم بعض الخروقات التي وقعت في
الساعات الماضيه حيث شهد محيط القصر
الرئاسي اطلاق ناري باسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه
واشتباكات المتقطعه وقصيره في شارع المطار
بحسب مراسل العربيه وعلى الضفه المقابله
للقصر الجمهوري في منطقه حله حمد للخرطوم
بحري سمع في ساعات الصباح الاولى اطلاق
نار وذوي مضادات ارضيه للدعم السريع اما
في اقصى الجنوب الغربي من الخرطوم فحلقت
مقاتلات الجيش فوق منطقه جبل اولياء
والى الشمال من بحر ايضا سمع اطلاق نار
بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه تحديدا في
ضاحيه شمبات
في هذه الاثناء وما تجدد للشبكات رغم
الهدنه المعلنه خلت الشوارع الرئيسيه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم من الماره فحين
شهدت المحل التجاريه التي فتحت ابوابها
جزئيه ولساعات محدوده ازدحاما سعيا للحصول
على المواد الغذائيه وبعض المستلزمات
الحيويه خاصه في ظل ازمه ارتفاع الاسعار
بشكل مضطرد
واظهرت صور خاصه بالعربيه خلو الشوارع
الرئيسيه في الخرطوم من الحركه المعتاده
مع استمرار الاشتباكات المتقطعه
اذا وشهدت عدد من المخابز شرق العاصمه
الخرطوم عوده التدريجيه للعمل وسط قله
الموارد وانعدام الامن الناس بامانه تعبت
يعني في ناس تعبت كثير في اطفال
فقدت حياته في اسره الان الحمد لله بدات
تفتح
والامور ماشيه الاخيره ربنا يصلح الحال
وضع سيء مواضيع سيل للغايه
لابعد الحدود
هذا اظهرت صور خاصه بالعربيه تصاعد اعمده
الدخان في المنطقه الصناعيه بالخرطوم بحري
مع استمرار للسماع اصوات انفجارات
واشتباكات متقطعه بين الجيش والدعم السريع
وقبل ذلك اكد بيان للجيش ان الاوضاع
مستقره في جميع ولايات السودان وبحسب
البيان حشدت قوات الدعم السريع اكثر من
خمسه وستين الف عنصر والفي مركبه للهجوم
على الخرطوم قبل الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن
الجيش استطاع التصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم
مشيرا الى ان الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين
من القتال من ان يخفض قدرات الدعم السريع
القتاليه الى النصف ومضيفا انه تم احباطه
عده تحركات لتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات الدعم
السريع قادمه من الغرب من الخرطوم
هذا واتواصل وحدات من الجيش السوداني
اجراء عمليه تمشيط في منطقه الخرطوم بحري
بينما تستمر للشبكات المتقطعه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مناطق متفرقه بالعاصمه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
وهذه اعزائي المشاهدين صور طردنا مباشره
الان من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم حيث
تتصاعد اعمده الدخان نتيجه نتيجه قصف
متبادل بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع رغم الهدنه المعلنه ولمده اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه بالطبع كما تشاهدون قصف عنيف
ادى الى هذه الاعمده من الدخان طبعا لا
نعرف حتى الساعه ما الذي استهدفه هذا
القصف ومن هي الجهه التي قامت بقصف هذا
الموقع ولكن الدخان يتصاعد كما تشاهدون
في المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع لقطات
فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى القصر
الجمهوري وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت قوات
الدعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على القصر
الجمهوري ومحيطه في الخرطوم بالاضافه الى
مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان كما
اكد احد قاده الدعم السريع ان سيطرتهم على
القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن مساعد دعم السريع
للحفاظ على ثروات الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا
نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب المسلح
بان هذا العمل الذي زجت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب
السوداني تواجد قوات الدعم السريع
ينضم الي لمزيد من المتابعه الان من خرطوم
بحري الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان محمد اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني واخر ما
رصدته من اشتباكات استاذ محمد
الامور
انفجرت الاحداث هنا بالتحديد في الخرطوم
بحري حيث تم قبل اقل من
عبر الطائرات لمعسكر المظلات التابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع وهذا يقع بالقرب من
جسر الشمبان كذلك تم قصف موقع اخر في حي
حله حمد بالخرطوم بحري علمنا ايضا كنعان
من بعض المصادر بان القصف الذي تم في
منطقه كافوري تم لمستودع خاص بالاسلحه
والذخائر تم استهدافه من قبل
الجيش
السوداني وكذلك ايضا لا زالت هناك
الطائرات تحلق في هذه اللحظات التي احدثك
فيها الان في سماء بحري يبدو ان هناك
استهداف لعدد من المنشات او لعدد من
المواقع التي ربما تسربت بعض المعلومات
محمد هل تسمعني
محمد يبدو ان الاتصال انقطع مع محمد اسحاق
عثمان كان يوافينا عن اخر مشاهداته لهذا
لهذه لهذه الاشتباكات وهذا القصف في خرطوم
بحري تحديدا
هذه الاشتباكات ولكن انقطع الاتصال بالطبع
منذ بدء هذه المواجهات والاتصالات متقطعه
وصعبه جدا مع السودان تحديدا مع العاصمه
الخرطوم ربما لنا عوده اليه فور جهوز
الاتصال مجددا للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
تحديدا هذا القصف منذ قليل وهذه الغارات
الجويه التي نفذها الجيش السوداني على بعض
المواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
ونبقى معكم مع هذه الصور من الخرطوم
لاعمده الدخان لهذا القصف الذي حصل منذ
قليل
محمد هل تسمعني
انقطع الاتصال محمد ارجو ان تتابع كنت
تتحدث عن اخر
الاشتباكات تحديدا هذه الغارات وما الذي
استهدفته طيب
وباقي المناطق محمد هل يمكن القول ان
الهدنه صامده هناك ام لا يعني حتى في
المناطق الاخرى لا يمكن القول ان الهدنه
صامده
نعم لا نستطيع ان نقول بان الهدنه صامته
بمنتهى القول لان هناك بعض الاشتباكات تبع
علمنا ايضا تدور الان في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم منطقه الصحافات وجبرى ايضا تعرضت
لاشتباكات عنيفه في هذه اللحظه كما قلت
قبل قليل كنعان الطيران لازال يحلق في
سماء بحري ويبدو بان هناك مزيد من الاهداف
سيتم قصفها في الوقت او في الدقائق
القادمه واسمع اصوات المضادات الارضيه في
هذه اللحظات ترد على تحليق هذه الطائرات
اذا كنعان يبدو اننا عدنا الى المربع
الاول واعاده المعارك اكثر شراسه وبراوه
في هذه اللحظات بصوره مفاجئه ولكن محمد
اذا كنت سمعت المندوب الدولي المندوب
الاممي الى السودان هو لا تحدث عن تفاؤل
اليوم وقال ما حرفيته ان الطرفين
على ارسال مندوبين عنهم الى طاوله
المفاوضات حتى انه رجح عقد جوله المفاوضات
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اي تفاصيل
لديك حول هذا الموضوع
نعم هذه هي الاخبار التي وردت الينا التي
ها او الخبر الذي انت ذكرته قبل قليل ولكن
المواقع الموقف الان كدعان على
الساحه والموقف فيما يلي المعارف
والاشتباكات لا اظنه يعني يمضي في في هذه
الجزئيه طالما ان المعارك تزداد على ارض
الواقع شراسه
لازارت لم تمضي عليها سوى ساعات تم
اختراقها قبل قليل فهذا مؤشر غير جيد ما
يحدث على الارض كالعام طيب بالنسبه الى
الاوضاع الانسانيه تحديدا فقدان السلع
الخبز المياه ما الذي يمكن ان نقوله اليوم
ام لا يعني الامور لا عادت الى حد ما الى
ان تكون شبه طبيعيه في بعض المناطق
والشوارع في الخرطوم ام لا لا يمكن قول
ذلك
في الصباح الباكر هنا في منطقه بحري او في
شمال بحري بالتحديد عند منطقه الحلفايه
والاحياء التي تجاورها كنا قد رصدنا في
صباح هذا اليوم بدايه عوده الحياه الى شبه
طبيعتها بدات البحاله التجاريه تفتح وبدا
الناس يتسوقون وبدات حركه الاسواق في
وضعها الطبيعي ولكن الان احدثك واسمع دويه
انفجار جديد قوي جدا يهز المباني هنا في
منطقه
شمال كوبري او جسر الحلفايه يبدو ان هذا
او هذه قذيفه وقعت قريبا من المكان الذي
انا اتحدث فيه على كل حال
هذه المناظر لا تبشر محمد هل يمكنك
تحديد ما الذي يستهدفه هذا القصف يعني هل
هنالك مواقع لطرفي القتال
تتعرض للقصف اذا كان يعني يمكنك تحديد
مكان
وموقع هذا القصف
نعم هذا الذي حدث قبل قليل اظنه من جديد
تم قصف معسكر المظلات بمنطقه شمبان هذا
المعسكر ظل مستهدفا من قبل الجيش به هو
كبير من الدعم السريع لا زال هذا المعسكر
من المعسكرات الكبيره ويقع في وسط الاحياء
في وسط حي شمبان بالتحديد في مدينه بحري
وربما الجيش يتعامل معه بحذر لوقوعه
بالقرب من او حواليه كثير من المشاكل الان
الدولي يستمر اظنها هي نفس المعسكر يتم
تدميره بالكامل في هذه اللحظات عبر سلاح
الطيران البدوي والاصوات قويه جدا تهتز
لها المباني في هذه اللحظات في مدينه بحري
طيب استاذ محمد بالنسبه الى موضوع عمليات
الاجلاء هل مازالت مستمره هل يعني تابعت
يمكن القول انه
يشاهد اناس بالعين المجرده ما زالوا
يريدون الخروج
وعن اي خطوط اجلاء او طرق يمكن الحديث
عنها
بالنسبه لعمليات الاجلاد حسب المصادر لا
زالت مستمره وان الجيش قد بعث بتعزيزات
اضافيه
وادي سيدنا
لمزيد من التعليم لعمليه البلاد لهذه
القاعده الجويه التي الان هي الاقرب من
هنا لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب اما فيما يلي
نزلت الهجره الداخليه هذه الحافلات لا
زالت قبل ساعه من الان كانت موجوده ولكنها
اختفت بفعل هذه الانفجارات التي حدثت قبل
قليل هذه الحافلات التي تقل المواطنين من
الخرطوم الى الولايات المختلفه تظهر عندما
يكون الوضع اكثر هدوءا ولكن عندما تزداد
الامور تعقيدا مثل الذي اشاهده في هذه
اللحظات تختفي ويصبح الشارع خاليا انتبه
من لا يوجد الان احد لا يوجد ضاره لا يوجد
محل مفتوحه
لا نرى غير هذه السحب من الدخان التي حتى
تغطي علينا لا نستطيع ان نشاهد بصوره
دقيقه من كثافه الدخان الذي اشاهده امامي
في هذه اللحظات من الخرطوم بحري الصحفي
محمد اسحاق عثمان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
اعزائي المشاهدين ومع استمرار المواجهات
يواجه الكثير من السودانيين مصاعب حقيقيه
في ممارسه حياتهم اليوميه بسبب الاقتتال
الدائر بين الجيش والدعم السريع فيما
يواجه عمال الاجره اليوميه معاناه مع
استمرار الاشتباكات حيث اختفت فرص العمل
بسبب الحرب
لكن معاناته والله بامانه كده يعني حكايه
ظرف صعب جدا جدا العمل متوقف
جاءت الحروب
ده بالنسبه لمحل انا
قاعد في بيتي
كيف كنتم تشتغلوا كيف كيف
الى الخرطوم مجددا ينضم الي لمزيد من
المتابعه الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه عمار اهلا
وسهلا بك المعلومات الوارده الينا منذ
قليل تفيد بتجدد للشبكات بشكل عنيف
وسجل يعني عدد من الغارات الجويه للجيش
على مواقع للدعم السريع في بعض الاحياء
الخرطوم هل من الممكن تاكيد هذه المعلومات
نعم يعني كانت هنالك غارات من سلاح الجو
في عدد من المناطق خاصه في مدينه بحرين
نشاهد اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من المدينه
الان حسب مصادر ميدانيه تحدثنا اليها
وتوصلنا الى عدد من المعلومات بان هناك
اشتباكات
دارت في منطقه بحري خاصه في المنطقه
الصناعيه ومنطقه كافوري ومنطقه جسر
الحلفايه كانت فيها عدد من الاشتباكات
المتقطعه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم الان بمحيط
القياده العامه للجيش وبمحيط المطار كانت
هنالك اشتباكات قبل لحظات نستمع فيها كنا
قبل لحظات لعدد من ذوي المدافع
والانفجارات وعدد من المنطقه الغربيه
المعازيه لمنطقه السوق العربي ايضا كانت
هنالك عمده الدخان تتصاعد من تلك المنطقه
قبل قليل كنا نستمع ايضا لعدد من صوت
الاعيره الناريه باتجاه الشرقي للمدينه ما
يعني ان المجال او الاتجاه الشرقي لمدينه
بحري ايضا قد دخل حيز هذه اشتباكات التي
تدور منذ اكثر من ساعتين من الان هذا ياتي
كله بالتزامن مع الحديث عن مفاوضات مع
الحديث عن موافقه الطرفين على مفاوضات مع
الحديث عن ممرات امنه لاجلاء عدد كبير جدا
من العالقين والمدنيين داخل الاحياء التي
تجري فيها اشتباكات ما بين القوات
المتحصنه فيها وبين ايضا القوات التي
تحاول ان تمشط تلك المناطق قوات الجيش
وهذه الاشارات ايضا تدل على كثير جدا من
الاشارات المتعدده فيما يخص كيف سيذهب
الجانبين الى عمليه تفاوض وهنالك ايضا
معركه على الارض هل يتم الاتفاق على ان
العمل العسكري ماض في غايته وعمل التفاوض
ايضا ماض في غايته ام ماذا سيكون شكل
الاتفاق هذه اسئله كثيره جدا بدات ترد على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لعدد كثير جدا من
المغردين وعدد كثير جدا من الذين يتفاعلون
بشكل واضح ومباشر نستمع في هذه اللحظات
لعدد من الرصاصات ربما في وسط العاصمه
وهنالك تصاعد لعمل الدخان نراها من على
البعد هذه هذا يدل على ان هذه المنطقه
ربما عدد الاشتباكات في مثل هكذا اوقات
وربما تمضي الاشتباكات في اللحظات القادمه
وربما بطبيعه هذه المعركه ومعتنا عليها من
معارك ربما تنخفض وترتفع وتراجع للوراء
وتذهب صعودا ايضا للامام وهذا يدل على ان
ساحه الميدان مشتعله والحديث عن التفاوض
ايضا مشتعل بشكل كبير وواضح وربما كل
السيناريوهات متوقعه
عمار هل يمكن تاكيد ما الذي يستهدفه هذا
القصف تحديدا يعني اي مواقع ام لا يعني من
حيث انت متواجد لا يمكن الجزم
نعم يعني بحسب المصادر والمعلومات التي
وردت الينا كان هنالك استهداف لعدد من
مرتكزات وارتكازات لقوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه كافوري ومنطقه بحري المنطقه الشرقيه
المنطقه الصناعيه كان استهداف لهذه القوات
التي تتمركز تتحصل في تلك المناطق بكثافه
في الجانب الشمالي ايضا في منطقه الحلفايه
كان هنالك استهداف لعدد من القوات في تلك
المنطقه وهذه المنطقه شهدت منذ عده ايام
اشتباكات عنيفه ما بين الجانبين وشهد
التمشيطا للجيش استطاع من خلالها ان يحدث
اختراقا وان يتقدم نوعا باتجاه قلب
المدينه القديمه في هذه اللحظات ايضا تعود
الانفجارات في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم نستمع
اليها ما بين لحظه واخرى وتشير هذه
الانفجارات الى هذه الاصوات الى اصوات
بعيده وربما تقترب من حي المطار وربما
تذهب الى المنطقه الغربيه يبدو ان هنالك
تكتيكا جديدا على ارض المعرق المعركه
ويبدو ايضا كذلك من خلال الدخان التي
تتصاعد ان هناك حريق لعدد من المركبات
العسكريه لم نتمكن من معرفه الاوضاع على
ارض الميدان بالتحديد ولكن هذا واضحا من
خلال الاعمده التي تتصاعد للدخان والنيران
والمدفعيه التي استمعنا اليها قبل قليل
طيب عمار بس انتم متابعتك يعني هذه
الاشتباكات تدور على خطوط تماس باتت
معروفه
ثابته لا تتغير يعني مناوشات كل واحد
متمدرس على خطوط تماس كل طرف
ويشتبك مع الاخر دون اي تقدم لاي طرف على
الاخر ام لا ثم الطرف يشن هجوما على طرف
اخر في محاوله لتعزيز مواقعه
نعم هذه هي طبيعه حرب المدن وهذا نلتمسه
بشكل واضح من خلال البيانات التي صدرت من
الجانبين الجيش تحدث بشكل واضح بانه يمارس
عمليه الصبر والنفس الطويل وعمليه التمشيط
لفرقه المشاه وكذلك عمليه التامين لعدد من
الممتلكات قوات الدعم السريع تحدثت في
بيان لها بانها ما زالت تتواجد في عدد من
المواقع الاستراتيجيه وهي تقصد القصر
الجمهوري والاذاعه والتلفزيون محيط
الاذاعه وعدد من المناطق التي انتشرت فيها
في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وشكلت طوقا امنيا
على عدد من المناطق فيما يخص مطار الخرطوم
وقياده الجيش والمنطق الشرقيه من مدينه
بحري وايضا كذلك منطقه شرق النيل وشرق
الخرطوم وهذه المناطق يعني يسهل فيها
لقوات الدعم السريعا تتحصن داخل الاحياء
او ان تشكل ارتكازات واضحه في عدد من
الشوارع ويصعب فيها ايضا على الجيش ان
يمارس فيها سلاح الجو غارات نسبه للكثافه
السكانيه الموجوده ونسبه ايضا كذلك عدد من
المستشفيات والمقر الصحيه التي بطبيعه
البنيه التحتيه في عدد من الاحياء في
السودان هي تتواجد داخل المقرات السكنيه
وتتواجد داخل الاحياء السكانيه بكثافه
الان نلاحظ بان حتى الحركه على مستوى
الشوارع لم تعد كما كانت في الصباح الباكر
كان هنالك نوعا من الحركه ونوعا من
المرونه في التنقل في عدد من الاحياء في
الشرق الخرطوم باعتبار ان هذه المنطقه
اصلا تستقل لعدد من الجهات التي تسير عدد
من الرحلات السفريه لعدد من الولايات
الشرقيه في هذه المنطقه واعتمدت هذه
المنطقه كمحطات للسفر لهذه الباصات وهذه
المركبات في هذه اللحظات ربما نشات هدوءا
نسبيا ولا نستمع لعدد من المناوشات او
الاشتباكات المتقطعه ولكن ربما تعود
باعتبار ان هنالك مناوشات قد بدات منذ
اكثر من ساعتين عمار ابقى معي ساعود اليك
بعد قليل اعزائي المشاهدين يواجه سودانيون
خطرا المواجهات العسكريه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع الدائره منذ ثلاثه اسابيع
وعلى الرغم من الاوضاع الامنيه المترديه
يضطر الكثير من المواطنين السودانيين
للتوجه الى اعمالهم ووظائفهم المختلفه
لاعاله اسرهم في ظل اوضاع عن اقتصاديه
وانسانيه صعبه
والله انا لازم اشتغل يعني في في الظروف
دي بيزداد لازم اشتغل عشان اقدر اكله اقدر
اشرف يعني السلع ذاته في زياده ويعني اي
حاجه زايده لازم انا اشتغل يعني
زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما في
يعني اي حاجه
مزيد من المتابعه الان انتقل الى جنوب
دارفور ينضم اليه من هناك الصحفي صالح ابو
علامه سيد صالح اهلا وسهلا بك الاوضاع في
جنوب دارفور كيف تبدو اخر مشاهداتك
وما المعلومات التي تصلكم من مدينه
الجنينه
صالح هل تسمعني
يبدو ان الاتصال متقطع وغير متوافر اعود
الى عمار في الخرطوم عمار اهلا بك مجددا
كلام المندوب الاممي حول السودان
بان الطرفين وافقاء على ارسال مندوبين الى
مفاوضات في محاوله للحل ورجح ان تكون
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مكان انعقاد
المفاوضات كيف يتابع السودانيون مثل هكذا
اخبار
ومصر تفاؤل المندوب الاممي في هذا الاطار
يبدو بان المعركه والمعارك بعد ان دخلت
الى الاسبوع الثالث هنالك انهاك كبير جدا
للقوات من الجانبين الجيش تحدث في بيان عن
انه استطاع ان يدمر ما نسبته 45 الى خمسين
في المئه من قدرات الدعم السريعه قوات
الدعم السريع تحدثت في بيان بانها ما زالت
تسيطر وتنفتح وتنتشر بشكل كبير في مركز
القرار في العاصمه الخرطوم هذان البيان
يشيران بنسبه واضحه بالتزامن مع حديث
المندوب الاممي فيما يتعلق بعمليه التفاوض
هنا اشارات كثيره جدا لان هذا التفاؤل
ربما لانه جرى انهاك لهذه القوات على ارض
الواقع وربما تم اقتناء لعدد كبير من
القيادات بان عمليه التفاوض ربما تمضي الى
غاياتها وحتى عمليه الحسم العسكري تمضي
بهذه العمليه سر هذا التفاؤل ربما يكمن
ايضا في ان كثير من الفاعلين الاقليميين
والدوليين قد تحدثوا بانه لابد من وقف هذه
الحرب الوزراء السابق دكتور عبد الله
حمدوك تحدث في اكثر من بيان واشار الى ان
الحرب الاهليه في السودان اذا ما قامت
فالحديث عن سوريا وعاد اليمن وعن ليبيا
سيكون مجرد نزهه باعتبار التركيب والصعبه
والهشاشه الامنيه الصعبه التي تدور في
السودان هذا الحديث ايضا ياتي بالتزامن مع
احاديث كثيره جدا وتقارير كثيره جدا نشرت
عن نزوحما ما يفوق الخمسين الف من
السودانيين في الاطراف في الخرطوم لا
يعتبر نزوح يعتبر خروج لمناطق اكثر امنا
ولكن في اطراف السودان هنالك عدد من
النازحين نزحوا الى تشاد هنالك من نزحوا
الى دوله اثيوبيا هنالك من نزحوا الى
جمهوريه مصر العربيه وهذه الاشارات كلها
تشير الى ربما تردي كبير جدا قد يجري في
الساحه الان خاصه مع انقطاع للكهرباء
انقطاع للمياه تردي في خدمات الاتصالات
على الجانب الميداني الاخر البنك المركزي
اشار الى انه استطاع ان يوفر خدمات فروعه
في عدد م الولايات والجيش يشير في بيانات
الى انه يبسط سيطرته على كل الولايات
باستثناء عدد من الولايات اذا هنالك نقاط
تدل على التفاؤل وهنالك نقاط ايضا تدل على
مؤشرات خطيره هذا يجعل الحديث الاممي ان
يكون اكثر تفاؤلا لحل كثير جدا او حذف
الاطراف المتقاطعه من اجل عمليه التفاوض
ربما لم تستطيع عدد من المبادرات
الامريكيه او حتى مبادرات اقليميه ان توقف
النار بشكل دائم وطويل لكن استطاعت من
خلال الهدن ان تحدث اختراقا ولو بالحديث
عن عمليه التفاوض وهنا يبرز دور المجتمع
الدولي والسودان اعتقدوا في هذه الاسره
يستطيع من خلالها ايضا ان يتمتع بما تقدمه
هذه الاسره الدوليه عمار تسهيل او هنالك
حديث ايضا كذلك عن الاليه الرباعيه
والثلاثيه طيب ابقى معي عمار ساعود اليك
بعد قليل انضم الي مجددا من جنوب دارفور
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه صالح اهلا وسهلا بك
ارجو ان تكون تسمعني الان كنت سالتك عن
اخر مشاهداتك شريط التطورات الميدانيه من
دارفور وما هي المعلومات التي تريدكم من
مدينه الجنينه
نعم قبل ان نذهب الى الجنينه دعنا نتحدث
عن الوضع هنا في جنوب دارفور بالامس عاده
الحياه تدريجيا اليوم هنالك اقبال كبير في
سوق مدينه نيالا خاصه سوق الجنوبي الذي
كنا فيه صباح اليوم
اربعين في المئه من حركه السوق عادت للعمل
اليوم بمدينه نيالا والاخبار القادمه من
غرب دارفور تشير الى انه اليوم تم نهب
مخزن للدواء في مستشفى غرب
شيء يجب ان نشير اليه ان هذه الاحداث
الاخيره
استهدفت مؤسسات حيويه دارفور في سابق
عندما كانت هنالك احداث كان لا يتم
استهداف للمستشفيات لا يتم استهداف
للمراكز الصحيه لكن الاحداث الاخيره هنالك
استهداف واضح للمراك هنالك دمار للبنيه
التحتيه هنالك اعمال شبهي منظمه لتخريب
حياه الناس لتدمير المنشات الحيويه وعلى
ذكر التدمير نحن هنا في مركز التحصين
التابع لوزاره الصحه بولايه جنوب دارفور
يمكن ان نرى من خلال الصوره هذا هذه
الصوره وهذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمبنى جرار
سقوط قذيفه داخل هذا المكان ايضا تم نهب
مركز التحصين الخاص بولايه جنوب دارفور
تماما تم نهب ثمانيه سيارات وتم نهب جميع
الثلاجات التي توضع فيها الامصال مثل
[موسيقى]
مصر ده الكلب والشلل وغيرها من الامصال
المهمه المنغزه لحياه الانسان اليوم جنوب
دارفور خاليه تماما من الامصال خاليه
تماما من الادويه المنقزه للحياه بسبب
عمليات التفلت وسبب عمليات التدمير
الكبيره التي طالت المنشاه هنا في هذا
المكان طيب صالح وانت تتحدث الاخبار
العاجله التي ترون اعزائي المشاهدين مجلس
السياده السوداني يؤكد ان رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي اتصل بالفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان
ومع الدعوه الى ضروره
التهدئه بالطبع يعني هذه الخبر العاجل
الان طيب صالح
دائما يقال ان الصراع والاقتتال يتخذ منحا
قبليا اثنيا وحتى قوميا هل يمكن لحظ ذلك
ام لا القتال عم يجري بين قوات الدعم
السريع ووحدات الجيش
هو القتال بدا بين وحدات الدعم السريع
والجيش هنا في نياله توجد اكبر قياده
لقوات الدعم السريع
دارفور
يمكن ان اتحول الصراع الى قبل خاصه بعد
الانتشار الكبير لسلاح اليوم هنا كل انسان
يريد ان يؤمن
نفسه يحمل سلاح من اجل ان يؤمن حياته خاصه
في ظل غياب
الدور الكبير للشرطه المنحصر فقط على
المؤسسه لا يوجد
لا يوجد تمشيط
لتدريس وهكذا السلاح المنتشر
الاهليه ويمكن
الى قتال
صالح للاسف الصوت يتقطع حتى الصوره ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك على اعتقد ان الفكره وصلت
شكرا جزيلا لك صالح ابو علامه كنت معي من
جنوب دارفور
عمار اعود اليك اتصال الان من رئيس
الاتحاد الافريقي بمجلس
رئيس
المجلس في السودان الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان هل من معلومات عن هويه المندوبين
في حال صحت وتاكدت المعلومات التي قالها
المندوب الامم الى السودان هل عرفت هويه
المندوبين الذين سيتم ارسالهم الى هذه
المفاوضات ام لا حتى الساعه لا وجود لاي
كلام حول هذا الموضوع عمار
يعني حتى نفهم هويه المندوبين كانت هنالك
اشاره في بيان الجيش اليوم بانه لن يسمح
بان تكون هنالك قوات خارج القوات المسلحه
وحمله تلك الخطيئه للنظام البائد وكان
الخلاف في الاتفاق الاطار الاخير فيما يخص
عمليه الدمج دمج قوات الدعم السريع داخل
الجيش والخلاف من الجانب الاخر من القوات
الدعم السريع كان يتحدث عن اطاله امد
الدمج الى عشر سنين وربما اقل من ذلك ليس
بكثير وهذه الاشاره تكمن في ان الاسم الذي
تم تسميته وتسربت عنه كثير من الاخبار
اللواء ابو بكر فقيري وهو مسؤول الترتيبات
الامنيه في الاتفاقيات الاخيره التي جرت
هذه او هذه اشاره ايضا الى ان ربما هويه
ممثل القوات المسلحه او اتجاه القوات
المسلحه اذا ما مضت الى تفاوض وهي تتحدث
اليوم عن تدمير اكثر 45 الى 55% من قدره
قوات الدعم السريع ربما هويه التفاوض يكن
في عمليه دمج او انسحاب او عمليه ترتيبات
امنيه جديده وفي الجانب الاخر من قوات
الدعم السريع حتى نفهم هويه المندوب من
الجانب الثاني وهي تتحدث عن اصلاح امني
ربما تمضي المفاوضات لهويه من يتقدمون
لهذه المفاوضات في هذه الجوانب ولكن هنالك
حديث ايضا يدور يعني كثير جدا ومسرب بشكل
واضح من تسريبات اخباريه ومعلومات تتسرب
بين فينا واخرى وتحدث عن امكانيه ان يتم
في البدء تهدئه طويله المدى بهذا القدر
عمار عمار ابو شريفه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك لن
اعود اليك في السياق هذه التغطيه عمار
شكرا جزيلا لكل جهودك في الاخبار العاجله
ايضا اعزائي المشاهدين الان نقابه اطباء
السودان تؤكد تسجيل
2244 اصابه بين المدنيين منذ المواجهات
اذا نقابه اطباء السودان تؤكد تسجيل الفين
ومائه واربعه وسبعين اصابه بين المدنيين
منذ بدء
المواجهات نقابه اطباء السودان تضيف ايضا
او تتحدث عن ارتفاع عدد القتل المدنيين
جراء الاشتباكات الى
قتيلا اذا نقابه اطباء السودان تؤكد
ارتفاع عدد القتل المدنيين جراء هذه
المواجهات الى
436 قتيلا
قال عبيده الدندراوي نائب المندوب الدائم
لمصر في خطاب له خلال الاجتماع الطارئ
لجامعه الدول العربيه ان بلاده تدعو الى
وقف فوري وشامل للنزاع في السودان كما
تدعو جميع الاطراف الى بدء جهودها لاعطاء
الاولويه للشعب السوداني ووقف اراقه
الدماء مؤكدا ان الحوار السياسي سيكون حلا
للازمه بشكل شامل الالتزام بالوقفه الفوري
والشامل للقتال فالى الاولويه لمصلحه
الشعب السوداني يجب ان تظهر من خلال
مبادره الاطراف ببذل كافه مساعيها لحقن
الدماء
وهو شرط اساسي للعوده للحوار السياسي
الحتمي الذي يمكن من خلاله حل الازمه بشكل
شامل استقبال مصر حتى صباح اليوم ما يقارب
اربعين الف مواطن سوداني اضافي عبر معبري
ارقين وقسطل بالحدود المصريه الجنوبيه
وفي متابعه لعمليه الاجلاء توافد المئات
من الرعايه الى ميناء بورسودان ضمن عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
نحن الان هنا في مدينه بورسودان لشرق
السودان سناخذ جوله لنتعرف على واقع هذا
المركز الرئيسي الذي يضم مئات من الاسر
الذي التي بدات في التوافد الى مدينه
بورسودان نبدا بالجهد الشعبي الذي يوازي
هذه الاعداد الكثيفه الان هيئه الموانئ
البحريه ممثله في غرفه الطوارئ عملت على
توفير هذا المستشفى المؤقت وهذه الغرفه
المؤقته للطوارئ للتعامل مع عدد من
الحالات التي قد ترد الى هذه المنطقه
حالات لسوريين وللسودانيين حتى تقدم لهم
الخدمات في هذا المركز الذي انشئ قبل
يومين في هذه المنطقه التي تضم ايضا كما
ذكرنا عددا من السوريين وعددا من اليمنيين
وايضا اضيفت اليهم اخرى من المقيمين
السودانيين الذين يحاولون ايضا عبر هذا
المركز ان
يغادروا هذه المنصه هنا في شرق السودان
الى عدد من الدول عبر من بورسودان السودان
عايش في لحظه رعب حقيقيه
يعني انا بتكلم عن جثث في الشوارع
شمينا لوحه الجثث ونحن جايين من الخرطوم
الضرب الغزف يعني بجد السودان في حاله
تعترف حقيقيه
3400 العدد كبير جوا البناء وبرا وعلى
الكورنيش الناس في الارض فرامل اطفال
مسنين مرضى بشكل عام احنا قاعدين هنا في
مكان يعني الله يجزاهم الخير يوفرون اصلا
مكان لكن احنا قاعدين في الارض ويعني اغلب
الناس قاعدين في الاراضي كلنا جايين اماكن
بعيده اغلبنا اتيم من الخرطوم
قرر الالاف من السودانيين نزوحها من
مناطقهم هربا من الاقتتال الدائر فيما
يتجه كثيرون الى بورتسودان من خلال حافلات
لنقل الركاب بات التكلفتها اغلى من
المعتاد بسبب نقص الوقود ويقول الاهالي في
ام درمان ان العائلات تتجه الى مواقف
الحافلات سيرا على الاقدام بسبب عدم توافر
وسائل للنقل مع استمرار الاشتباكات
المسلحه
الخرطوم للولايات فبرده يعني الحاجه صعبه
شديد يعني اول كلمه ماجد خاشش الشعبي لقيت
دفار بعشره
دفار باقل تذكره للبيض بعشر فما بالك يعني
باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
الباص هذا سعرها حتكون كيف
يعني
لو بنفس الحساب بندر
وفي متابعه الجهود السعوديه بشان عمليات
الاجلاء افاد مراسل العربيه بوصول سفينه
حربيه امريكيه تقل
318 اشخاص من سته عشره جنسيه قادمه من
السودان الى ميناء جده الاسلاميه واضاف ان
جده استقبلت 26 سفينه اجلاء قادمه من
السودان حتى الان بالاضافه الى 49 رحله
اجلاء جويه من بورتسودان وصلت الى جده تقل
اكثر من
2200 شخص
هذا وبدات نيجيريا في اجلاء اول دفعه من
مواطنيها معظمهم من طلاب الجامعات من
السودان الى مصر بعد ان ظلوا محاصرين في
جامعه افريقيا الدوليه في الخرطوم لاكثر
من اسبوعين وقال المتحدث باسم الوكاله
الوطنيه لاداره الطوارئ في نيجيريا ان 7
حافلات غادرت الخرطوم متوجهه الى مصر على
ان يتم نقلهم الى نيجيريا بطائرات الشحن
العسكريه النيجيريه وشركه طيران خاصه
وتعمل نيجيريا على اجلائه 3500 شخص من
خمسه الاف يقطنون السودان
يعني كما تشاهدون اجلاء ثلاثه الاف
وخمسمائه نيجيري من السودان اغلبهم من
طلاب الجامعات على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه افاد مراسل العربيه بان
التقديرات تشير الى دخوله نحو 15 الف
سوداني الى مصر عبر المنافذ البريه ياتي
ذلك فيما يصل السودانيون الذين قرروا
الفرار من النزاع عن طريق منفذ قسطل البري
لتكون مدينه ابو سمبل اولى محطات
استقبالهم
اهالي المدينه حرصوا على تقديم كافه انواع
المساعده للنازحين نتابع
عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من بعبر قسطنب البري الوجوه المرهقه من
عناء الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع
استقبال اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود
المصريه الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين
ما تيسر من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي
السودان قبل استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه
اسوان احنا طبعا لازم نقف جنب شقاءنا
السودانيين في الازمه اللي هم فيها واحنا
عملنا المبادره دي مع شباب القريه عندنا
وحسينا ان احنا اهل البلد يعني يعني
الخدمه اللي قدموها لنا ما حسستني انه ليس
مازلنا في السودان يعني بعض القادمين لا
يملكون الاموال اللازمه لاستكمال الرحله
احدى المجموعات النازحه توجهت الى وسط
المدينه لتفاجا برد فعل الاهالي الذين
قاموا بجمع المساعدات المطلوبه
والله انا يعني سم ده ما نزل مو سمبل وانا
بقينا الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم
والله كل خير يعني احنا
وابناء وقفوا مع بعض وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونه للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم وساق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
جاينا تعليمات من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء
تامين شامل سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو
لقينا برضو مساعدات من جهات تانيه بفضل
الله محدش مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعفاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنه الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الصحيه اكد المسؤول
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني اسامه
ابو بكر للعربيه ان المساعدات الطبيه
المرسله من الصليب الاحمر ستساعد كثيرا في
توفير الخدمات الطبيه للسودانيين الذين
يعانون من الاقتتال الدائر بين قوات الجيش
والدعم السريع
المساعدات من برنامج الغذاء العالمي او اي
من المؤسسات العالميه اكيد حتستفيد منها
المواطنين وضحايا النزاع المسلح ودائما
نحن عندنا الشراكات مع كل هذه المنظمات
التابعه للامم المتحده وغيرها في انه هي
بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر بالذات في توزيع
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعده صحيه او
انسانيه على مستوى السودان فضلا عن
الخرطوم لانه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يعتمد في عمله اساسا على متطوعين متخصصين
في مجالات مختلفه يبلغ عددهم النصف مليون
متطوع في جميع انحاء السودان
ابو بكر قال ايضا للعربيه ان المساعدات
الطبيه تضم المواد التي تحتاجها
المستشفيات لتقديم المساعدات الطبيه
للسودانيين وانها تشكل انفراجه في الازمه
الصحيه ما نحتاج
للمعينات الطبيه بالذات مختلف المعينات
الطبيه والنستلزمات الطبيه والشحنه
القادمه من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
هي فيها كل المستلزمات الطبيه حسب
الاولويات المطروحه بحكم انه اللجنه
الدوليه لحمه عندها جثه قائمه منذ عشرات
السنين في السودان ونعمل مع بعض سويا لذلك
كل الاشياء الجايه في الشحنه دي هي اشياء
عندها اولويه طبعا الشحنه يعني
هي ثمانيه طن او 8000 كيلو يعني وبالتالي
حتحدث انفراج كبير جدا
في هذه الاثناء اعلن برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه عن استئناف انشطته في السودان
لتقديم المساعدات العاجله في ظل تدهور
الوضع الانساني في البلاد من جهه قالت
المديره التنفيذيه للبرنامج سند مكين على
حسابها في تويتر ان الازمه الحاليه في
السودان تدفع الملايين الى هاويه الجوع ما
ادى لرفع التعليق المؤقت لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالميه في السودان وفي منتصف ابريل
الماضي قال البرنامج انه اوقف مؤقتا جميع
انشطته في السودان بعد مقتل ثلاثه من
موظفي في الشباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السري
هذا هو يواجه ثلث سكان السودان البالغ
عددهم حوالي 45 مليون نسمه ازمه جوع
متصاعده ما دفع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
لوصف الوضع الانساني في البلاد بالكارثي
معاناه على معاناه تجثم على قلوب
السودانيين اما كساد يؤرق محلهم التجاريه
او شبح جوع يلوح في الافق السودان يشكو
ازمه تتراكم عليها ازمات سابقه متداخله
الوضع الانساني كارثي او كما وصفه الامين
العام للامم المتحده بلغ نقطه الانهيار
السودان على السلطه في السودان لا يعرض
مستقبل هذا البلد للخطر فحسب انه يضيء
فتيله يمكن ان ينفجر عبر الحدود ويسبب
معاناه هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه الى
الوراء لعقود
صراع فاقم معاناه المدنيين الساعين وراء
لقمه العيش تقرير اممي سابق اوضح ان ثلث
السكان اصلا كانوا يعيشون على المساعدات
الانسانيه قبل اندلاع الصراع ووفق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يواجه خمسه عشر مليون شخص
انعداما حادا في الامن الغذائي ومع اندلاع
الصراع باتت ولايات السودان الثمانيه عشره
تحت رحمه مساعدات قد تتوقف بسبب اغلاق
ممرات الاغاثه حيث تمثل دارفور التحدي
الاكبر من الناحيه الانسانيه بحسب
المنظمات الامميه وتليها عده ولايات هي
الاكثر تضررا من النزاع والتدهور
الاقتصادي كالخرطوم وكسلا والنيل الابيض
وجنوب كردفان لا طعام لملايين الاطفال
تصريح سبق صراع السلطه لمسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان ومع
اول مواجهات اندلعت فان ارقام الذين
سينامون جائعين قد تتضاعف محمد السيف
العربيه
طبعا هذه مشاهد تردنا الان ومقاطع فيديو
نشرتها قوات الجيش السوداني
لوحدات الجيش وهي تسيطر على مقر سلاح
الاشاره في الخرطوم بحري اذا الجيش
السوداني ينشر مقاطع فيديو لسيطره قواته
على مقر السلاح الاشاره في الخرطوم بحري
كما تظهر هذه المشاهد
والكلام
للجيش السوداني
لسيطره
قوات من الجيش السوداني على مقر سلاح
الاشاره في الخرطوم بحري وهذه فيديوهات
نشرها الجيش السوداني منذ قليل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين تغطيتنا للتطورات
السودانيه مستمره ولكن الان الى طائفه من
الاخبار الدوريه فقد خرج
الفرنسيون للتظاهر في فرنسا لاحياء عيد
العمال ولمواصله الاحتجاج رفضا لقانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس ايمن
والماكرون
وتوقعت النقابات الفرنسيه نزول ما يصل الى
مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى الشوارع
وقال الامين العام للاتحاد الديمقراطي
الفرنسي للعمل انهم يتوقعون مشاركه مئات
الالاف من المتظاهرين موضحا ان نقابات
اعدت 300 نقطه تجمع في مختلف انحاء البلاد
لاحياء عيد الاول من مايو
هذا واندلعت مواجهات بين المتظاهرين وقوات
الشرطه في مدينه نامت الفرنسيه حيث
استخدمت الشرطه القنابل المسيله للدموع
لتفريق المتظاهرين
[موسيقى]
وفي جنوب فرنسا تجمع المتظاهرون في ثلوج
في مسيره بمناسبه عيد العمال واحتجاجا على
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الحكومي الذي اقره
الرئيس امل مكروه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا هذه صور تردنا من العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس للمواجهات
والتظاهرات بالطبع توقعات بمئات الالاف
سيشاركوا في هذه التظاهرات
للاحتجاج على نظام التقاعد الذي اقراته
الحكومه الفرنسيه
وايضا بمناسبه عيد العمال الذي يصادف في
الاول من مايو اذا مزيد من الحشود
والمتظاهرين في شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس وفي مدن اخرى يعني كنا شاهدنا
التظاهرات ومواجهات في ثلوج وفي نانت
وغيرها من المدن الفرنسيه
الى باريس معي من هناك لمزيد لمزيد من
المتابعه مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا حسين
فيا قنيبر حسين جديد المشهد التظاهرات
والاحتجاجات وابرز مشاهداتك في هذه
الاوقات
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع حسين لنا عوده
اليه في سياق النشرات والتغطيات المقبله
اذا هذه المشاهد
للتظاهرات والمواجهات يعني تسجل بعض
المواجهات بين قوات الشرطه وبين المحتجين
في عدد من شوارع العاصمه باريس وايضا في
عدد اخر من المدن الفرنسيه
المتظاهرون يريدون من الحكومه الفرنسيه
التراجع عن مشروع
قانون التقاعد الذي اقراته الحكومه
الفرنسيه
ولكن حتى الساعه لا وجود لاي مؤشرات على
ان الحكومه الفرنسيه ستتراجع
عن هذا القانون اذا توقعات
بمئات الاف المتظاهرين في
المدن الفرنسيه احتجاجا على قانون التقاعد
طبعا بعض المتظاهرين يحرقون
بعض الاشياء في الشوارع لا ندري ما هي
ربما يعني هذه الدراجه
ولكن لا ندري لمن هذه الدرجه
ونشاهد شرطه مكافحه الشغب
تتابع هذا الموضوع بالطبع وتسجل بعض
المواجهات بين
الجانبين هذه قنابل مسيله للدموع بين
الطرفين ترمى الان
في هذه المواجهات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
[تصفيق]
والمتظاهرين طبع توقعات بان تعرف هذه
المواجهات
مع
تواصل وصول
الحشود من المتظاهرين مدير مكتب قناه
العربيه في باريس حسين صادق انضم اليه
الان حسين جديد المشهد من عندك في هذه
الاوقات وابرز مشاهداته
هل تسمعني جيدا انت على الهواء حسين
[تصفيق]
المصر الغزير الذي امر قبل قليل هنا لم
يفرق هذه الحشود لا ادري ما اذا كنتم
تشاهدون الصوره طالب نعم نشاهد بام العين
يعني نشاهد هذه يعني ولا الصوره مباشره
اولا يعني كما تذكر هنا كما تقول
المواجهات قنابل مسيله للدموع يعني سقوط
الامطار وكل ذلك تفضل حسين
هذه الحشود
لك الانطلاق الى
المتظاهرين تستعد للتوجه في مسيره طويله
نحو ساحه الامه هذه هي التظاهره المركزيه
في باريس بالتزامن معها بل سبقتها تظاهرات
في عده مدن اخرى من بينها اليوم ومارسيليا
ومونسيليا وسلوم ونيس وكان وليل
وبورد
كل هذه التظاهرات التي دعت اليها النقادات
الثماني الرئيسيه تهدف حسين حسين سنكون
معك في نشرات لاحقه لانه انتهت فتره
التغطيه الان من دبي ولكن الزميل نايف
الاحمري سيصحبكم في الساعه المقبله من
الرياض اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات